people may look down on these things
like a dandelion flower or cattail and
say like this is just some common weed
how can this be used by the Michelin
star restaurant sir I think that's
what's changing people want to go back
to things that are sort of law
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is tama Matsuoka Wong and I'm a
forager when I first heard the word
forager I didn't really know what it
meant but then I found out that it's
sort of like doing a dance with nature
and finding the secret foods in the wild
most of the restaurants I work with are
Michelin star restaurants such as
Gramercy Tavern restaurant Danielle
Cosme and a number of others I came from
a different background I didn't study
horticulture I didn't study botany I
went to Harvard Law School and I
practiced a career for decades in
Investment Banking
I always liked nature I always liked
food I was a failed gardener I was
trying to find good recipes for my weeds
that I found that worker to eat so
people just started asking me for this I
started getting more and more involved
it was super creative impactful and it
just took me most of the stuff that I
get is from around my house but you you
can find common weeds anywhere
probably ideal was between four and five
hundred different plans a year some of
my favorite ingredients are sumac wild
Brassica I like wild shiso and cattail
shoots people don't realize that all
this stuff around them is good food and
two meters of ground you could have 50
different plants 50 and that's nature
and can be something amazing that you
can enjoy you don't even have to go too
far together
when I first started bringing my weeds
to a very elevated restaurants oh wow
that's beautiful
I didn't know you're supposed to call
chef chefs because I'm just a forager so
forget that we are going to pickle them
with chicken broth and uh some chili
flakes the thing I love is that the
chefs just see the huge beauty in every
of these plants they love them like
their little jewels and I don't feel
like it's my product I feel like it's
matrice products and that they respect
the plant so it's a huge bond it's not
about a chef for me it's about the play